[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen an einem Tag an dem
ein Gericht Deutschlands politische
Agenda bestimmt und das gleich auf zwei
Gebieten es ist nicht irgendein Gericht
sondern das höchste dieses Landes das
über die Verfassung wacht und jetzt
feststellt so schnell wie die
Regierungskoalition ihr heizungsgesetz
durchs Parlament bringen will das könnte
zu schnell sein jedenfalls besteht nach
Auffassung aus Karlsruhe die Gefahr dass
die Abgeordneten nicht ausreichend
informiert prüfen können über was sie da
abstimmen sollen jetzt gibt's also keine
Gebäude Energiegesetz Abstimmung morgen
sondern erst nach der Sommerpause genau
das was insbesondere der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister unbedingt verhindern
wollte Karl Hinterleitner
das sind die Leute die die wärmewende
vor Ort umsetzen eric wallmeier ist
Bürgermeister von Ostercappeln bei
Osnabrück er und seine Leute müssen den
Bürgern das heizungsgesetz erklären die
Berliner Politik macht es Ihnen dabei
nicht gerade leicht diese
Geschwindigkeit wie Meinungen sich
ändern wie Vorschläge durchs Land
getrieben werden das überfordert die
Bürger und von daher wünsche ich mir
dass wir jetzt noch mal konzentriert und
mit einer gewissen
Konstanz dann auch in die Entwicklung
eines solchen Gesetzes einsteigen die
neueste Wendung die erfolgreiche Klage
des CDU Abgeordneten Thomas Heilmann
erst vier Monate lang Diskussionen über
ein ohnehin sperriges Gesetz und jetzt
kommt es erstmal nicht für die
Parlamentarier sei nicht genug Zeit
gewesen zu Beratung das Gesetz dass der
Bundestag morgen verabschieden sollte
gestoppt denn wenn man ehrlich ist
leiden die Verfahren des Deutschen
Bundestages seit längerem auch schon in
der letzten Legislaturperiode
an
mangelnder Sorgfalt
insbesondere durch überhöhtes Tempo
ausgelöst wird dieses Tempo ist nun
gebremst das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dippiert vor
allem SPD und Grüne sie hatten das
Gesetz unbedingt schnell vom Tisch
bringen wollen der Plan geplatzt wir
hätten das als ampelfraktion sehr gerne
gemacht weil aus unserer Sicht notwendig
ist dass die Menschen in diesem Land
Klarheit bekommen wir haben aber
natürlich sehr großen Respekt vor der
Entscheidung von Karlsruhe von den
Richterinnen dort der FDP scheint die
Verzögerung nicht viel auszumachen sie
sitzt stattdessen auch noch Spitzen
gegen grün
für uns als Freie Demokraten ist
entscheidend nicht wann dieses Gesetz
kommt sondern das ist ein gutes Gesetz
wird die Vereinbarung der
koalitionsfraktion haben genau das
möglich gemacht wir haben jetzt ein sehr
guten Gesetzentwurf der deutlich besser
ist als das alte heizungsgesetz der
großen Koalition und gleichzeitig
deutliche Änderungen am Gesetzentwurf
von Robert Habeck gemacht hat Harmonie
hört sich anders an beobachte des
politischen Berlin sehen auf Dauer sogar
den Zusammenhalt der Koalition gefährdet
eine Dynamik des Miteinanders ist aus
dem was wir im Moment erleben nicht
erkennbar bei dieser Ampel da gibt es
wechselseitig nur Misstrauen keinen
Vertrauen sofern es ist schwer
vorstellbar dass man auch
interessenunterschiede langfristig
weiter überbrückt der heutige Tag eine
Ohrfeige für die Regierung der Streit
ums heizungsgesetz ist verschoben auf
September fortsetzung folgt
die Bundestagspräsidentin ist bei uns
frau Präsidentin guten Abend
wie würden Sie denn das in einem Wort
jetzt beschreiben was da gestern am
späteren Abend vom Verfassungsgericht
kam
wie soll man das beschreiben zum einen
ist es ein gutes Recht eines
Abgeordneten zu sagen dass seine Rechte
möglicherweise verletzt werden und
insofern ist die Entscheidung gestern
Abend getroffen worden dass Gebäude
Energiegesetz morgen nicht auf die
Tagesordnung aber in einem Wort hatte
ich eigentlich gefragt würden Sie sagen
das ist eine Rüge in Rüffel oder
das ist eine ernstzunehmende Mahnung
ernstzunehmende Mahnung haben wir
zumindest in zwei Worten hinbekommen
fühlen sie sich denn dabei auch jetzt
angesprochen hätten sie als Präsidentin
sicherstellen müssen dass die
Abgeordneten genug Möglichkeiten zur
Abwägung zur Information und Prüfung
haben
ich alleine kann das nicht sicherstellen
weil natürlich auch immer Mehrheiten
entscheiden wann sie welchen
Tagesordnungspunkt auf die Tagesordnung
setzen aber ich habe ja schon sehr früh
am 6 März darauf hingewiesen dass wir
Gesetzgebungsverfahren nicht immer nur
in einem krisenmodus entscheiden sondern
dass es eben auch Beratungszeiten für
Abgeordnete geben muss für die
Opposition aber auch für alle anderen
Abgeordneten und auch für die
Sachverständigen unser und das ist mir
ein wichtiges Anliegen und das habe ich
im März schon gesagt nur hat sie
offenbar niemand gehört in der eigenen
Partei und auch in den anderen Ampel
Fraktionen nicht
ja das ist bedauerlich und insofern ist
jetzt eine Entscheidung getroffen worden
die man wirklich ernst nehmen muss was
wir immer wieder unterstellt wird ist
dass der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
insbesondere und der Bundeskanzler das
Thema möglichst aus dem heißen Wahlkampf
in Hessen und Bayern raushalten wollten
wie es dann immer so schön heißt das
Thema abräumen könnten sie das verstehen
ich kann zumindest verstehen weil wir
über dieses Thema an sich ja schon sehr
lange diskutieren übrigens nicht nur im
Parlament sondern auch in der
Bevölkerung und dass man vor einer
Sommerpause entscheiden will das kann
ich nachvollziehen weil man eben auch
sagen will die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
müssen jetzt nach einer langen Debatte
auch Klarheit haben auf der anderen
Seite ist es aber so dass eben Verfahren
und Abläufe im Parlament eingehalten
werden müssen das ist die andere Seite
und die gehört eben auch dazu jetzt also
erst nach der Sommerpause entschieden
werden es heißt allerdings aus dem
beteiligten Fraktionen bereits
Änderungen soll es ausdrücklich nicht
mehr geben da stellt sich ja so ein
bisschen die Frage welchen Sinn macht
denn dann mehr Zeit zur Prüfung
überhaupt nur wenn es schon vorher heißt
geändert wird nichts egal wie die
Prüfung ausgeht
es gibt ja einen Abschluss im Ausschuss
wir haben heute die das Berichterstatter
das Ergebnis des Ausschusses auch
verteilen lassen an alle abgeplenum
überwiesen und das Gericht hat ja in der
Sache noch nicht entschieden sondern sie
haben nur gesagt sie die Ampel oder ich
sag mal die Koalition kann dieses Gesetz
am Freitag nicht auf die Tagesordnung
setzen inhaltlich ist nicht entschieden
will das Gericht ja auch gar nicht
entscheiden das entscheidet ja nur über
die Zeitspanne die nötig ist damit man
sich gut informieren kann als
volksvertreterin als Volksvertreter die
Frage ist nur wenn jetzt von der Ampel
bereits gesagt wird wir ändern sowieso
nichts mehr welchen Sinn macht denn dann
noch mehr Zeit zur Information aber das
wäre ja am Freitag auch so gewesen die
Ampel hat ja einen Entwurf vorgelegt der
hätte morgen in der zweiten dritten
Lesung verabschiedet werden sollen jetzt
haben alle Abgeordneten noch mal Zeit
bis zur zweiten dritten Lesung nehme ich
über die Sommerpause sich in diesem
Gesetzentwurf einzuarbeiten und
gegebenenfalls sogar noch
Änderungsanträge zu stellen das ist das
Recht der Oppositionsfraktion und das
ist ja dadurch nicht genommen jetzt
passiert durchaus häufiger sie kennen
das das abends noch viele
seitenänderungen reinkommen bei solchen
Gesetzen und die dann am nächsten Morgen
bereits beraten werden sollen was sagt
denn das über die handwerklichen
Fähigkeiten einer Regierung wenn Sie
bereits jetzt schon fast so viele
Gesetze im allverfahren durchgedrückt
hat wie die Vorgängerregierung in ihrer
kompletten Legislatur das ist genau das
was ich am 6 märz in meinem Brief den
ich an die Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
Ampel aber auch an den
Kanzleramtsminister geschrieben habe
dass es bei Debatten eben wichtig ist
dass parlamentarische Verfahren nicht
außer Kraft zu setzen und ich hatte den
Eindruck im März das eine Art
krisenmodus den wir in der pandemiezeit
hatten dass der weiter fortgesetzt wird
und ich bin auf der einen Seite eben
auch dafür uns nicht zu stark in den
Verfahren zu
festzurren denn das Parlament braucht
auch eine gewisse Freiheit schnell
entscheiden zu können das hat man in
Krisen zwar bei der Finanzkrise gesehen
ich bin ja jetzt auch schon ein paar
Jahre im Parlament oder eben auch bei
der Pandemie wir dürfen uns die
Flexibilität die wir manchmal in
Krisenzeiten brauchen nicht nehmen aber
was nicht geht ist aus jedem fachtthema
ein krisenmodus zu machen das ist auch
ein handwerkliches Problem einfach von
der Art wie man Politik gestaltet oder
ich glaube dahinter steckte einfach dass
wir uns an diese schnellen Verfahren
gewöhnt haben und wir müssen uns jetzt
davon wieder entwöhnen weil weil es eben
Themen gibt die nicht so allbedürftig
sind dass sie zu einer bestimmten Zeit
zu einer bestimmten Frist entschieden
werden müssen darauf habe ich einfach
hingewiesen und ich glaube die
Sommerpause kann jetzt allen noch mal
nutzen darüber nachzudenken und die
Mahnung des Gerichts ernst zu nehmen
sagt die Bundestagspräsidentin double
Bars herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
und das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen vor zwei Stunden aufgezeichnet
nachher im heute journal Update Fragen
von Christopher Wehrmann an den Berliner
CDU-Abgeordneten Thomas Heilmann wir
haben ihn gerade kurz gesehen der die
ganze Sache zum Verfassungsgericht
gebracht hatte und jetzt von einem
Weckruf spricht
und dann hat das Parlament in den
letzten Tagen vor der Sommerpause noch
eine zweite Aufgabe abzuarbeiten die ihm
die verfassungsrichterinnen und Richter
mit auf den Weg gegeben hatten
allerdings schon vor drei Jahren damals
fällt er das Karlsruher Gericht eine
Entscheidung buchstäblich überleben und
Tod und stellte fest in diesem Land darf
man selbst entscheiden ob man seinem
Leben ein Ende setzen will auch mit
Hilfe Dritter das Verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen Sterbehilfe wurde
gekippt
nur eine konkrete gesetzliche
Neuregelung stattdessen fehlt der Rahmen
auch für Ärzte innerhalb dessen
Sterbehilfe möglich sein soll fehlt der
Bundestag hatte heute die Möglichkeit
das zu ändern und hat sie nicht genutzt
die Gründe dafür zeigt wie nie hier
es hat nicht an der Nachdenklichkeit
gefehlt nicht am Zuhören auch dort nicht
wo sonst gerne mal gebrüllt wird es hat
auch nicht an Beispielen gefehlt von
denen die Abgeordneten erzählen um ihre
Position zu verstärken weil Geschichten
ja Überzeugungskraft haben wie hier die
über einen Mann der Scheid hat sein
Leben zu beenden
den jungen Mann der an einer bipolaren
Störung und während Depressionen leidet
hatte plötzlich ein starkes Gefühl
ergriffen jetzt sterben zu wollen er
sprang von der Golden Gate Bridge in San
Francisco und überlebte im Gegensatz zu
99% der anderen gesprungenen Person er
erzählt selbst dass er noch im freien
Fall die tief bereut habe gesprungen zu
sein oder umgekehrt die Geschichte über
einen chronisch kranken Mann der zudem
einen Unfall erleidet und Hilfe er sehnt
er befürwortet als jemand der das Leben
bejaht der das Leben liebt der an seinem
Leben hängt ausdrücklich unseren
freiheitlichen Entwurf und warum tut er
das weil er diesen als ein mentalen
Befreiungsschlag empfindet es gibt für
jede Position Argumente aber die die
hier sind schaffen es nicht sich
gegenseitig zu überzeugen ein
fraktionsübergreifender Entwurf sah so
aus Betroffene sterbewillige sollten
sich zweimal mit einem Abstand von
mindestens drei Monaten bei einem
Facharzt vorstellen das ganze
grundsätzlich strafbar für die Ärzte mit
Ausnahmen
mit unserem Gesetzentwurf eröffnen wir
erstmals Ärztinnen und Ärzten die
Möglichkeit ein Tod bringendes Mittel
für ein assistierten Suizid zu
beschreiben sagen sie ja und nicht nein
unser Gesetzentwurf steht dabei fest auf
dem Boden unseres Grundgesetzes denn
dieses Grundgesetz ist eine Verfassung
des Lebens und nicht des Sterbens der
andere Entwurf sah den Aufbau eines
niedrigschwelligen Beratungsnetzwerk vor
Gespräche dort sollten ähnlich wie beim
Schwangerschaftsabbruch mit einem
Beratungsschein Enden Straffreiheit
sollte für Ärzte gelten
wichtig ist uns vor allem dass wir die
Menschen nicht schon wieder alleine
lassen alleine mit ihrem Schmerz ihre
Angst und ihrem Wunsch gehen zu dürfen
deshalb brauchen wir eine rechtssichere
Lösung am Ende aber scheitern beide
Entwürfe meine These ist das sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist das an dieser
Legislaturperiode was passiert ich hatte
jetzt auch nicht auf den Kollegen und
Kollegen herum sondern ich brauche die
ja es muss jetzt schleunigst also
vielleicht nicht morgen aber dann nach
der Sommerpause auch wieder ein Anlauf
geben denn im Moment haben wir dann das
was wir in alle nicht wollen einen
ungeregelten Zustand es fehlten bei der
Abstimmung unter anderem der
Bundeskanzler und der
Gesundheitsminister eine Debatte
gepresst in den heizungsampelstreit sie
hätte mehr verdient gehabt
sprechen wir noch grundsätzlich darüber
mit sarattacker unserer ZDF
Rechtsexpertin genannt Sarah was geht
denn jetzt in Sachen Sterbehilfe in
Deutschland wenn diese Lücke die das
Verfassungsgericht ja gerissen hat in
den Regelungen vom Bundestag erstmal
nicht gefüllt wird
Herr aktuell gilt dass jeder in
Deutschland frei entscheiden darf ob
wann und wie er sterben will und vor
allem sich beim Sterben auch helfen
lassen darf denn das Recht auf
selbstbestimmte sterben ist seit der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts fest im
Grundgesetz verankert abgeleitet aus
Artikel 1 der Menschenwürde das bedeutet
konkret auch ein gesunder 18-Jähriger
darf sich das Leben nehmen und er darf
sich vor allem dabei helfen lassen die
Beihilfe auch die geschäftsmäßige
Beihilfe zum Suizid ist aktuell
straffrei aber das
Betäubungsmittelgesetz verbietet es
aktuell Ärzten bestimmte hochwirksame
todbringende Medikamente zu verschreiben
deshalb gehen immer noch Menschen ins
Ausland um beim Suizid würdevoll
begleitet zu werden
und das Verfassungsgericht hat er jetzt
keinen keine Möglichkeit zu dem
Parlamentariern gesagt dass sie jetzt
dringend daran etwas ändern sollten oder
dieser Zustand kann theoretisch aus
Karlsruhe sich doch erstmal so bestehen
bleiben absolut sie haben den Politikern
empfohlen Richtlinien und Regeln
aufzustellen aber es kann auch erstmal
weiterhin unreguliert bleiben gut und
dann reden wir Sarah noch über den
weiteren Beschluss der in Berlin ja
aktuell vor Ort macht den weiteren
Beschluss des Verfassungsgerichts der
die geplante Verabschiedung des
heizungsgesetzes morgen erstmal Stopp
warum mischt sich dieses Gericht jetzt
in ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren so massiv
ein
dieser Beschluss kam tatsächlich
überraschend denn grundsätzlich gilt das
Parlament das heißt die
Parlamentsmehrheit entscheidet wie
schnell oder langsam ist ein Gesetz auf
den Weg bringt da greift das
Bundesverfassungsgericht normalerweise
nicht ein hier das Gericht aber nachdem
es angerufen wurde die Folgen abgewogen
und ganz klar gesagt auf der einen Seite
könnten durch den engen Zeitplan die
abgeordnetenrechte verletzt sein und auf
der anderen Seite ist es für den
Bundestag zumindest möglich die
Abstimmung auch ein paar Tage später
stattfinden zu lassen denn die
Entscheidung ist ja nur dass das Gesetz
diese Woche nicht verabschiedet werden
darf dadurch stellt sich jetzt natürlich
aber grundsätzlich die Frage ob und wie
das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich
künftig in die Zeitpläne des Parlaments
einmischt welche Eile ist okay und
welche Eile ist zu eilig das heißt
unterm Strich bleibt eine erstaunliche
Entscheidung mit offenen Folgen für
künftige Gesetzgebungsvorhaben
interessante Analyse wie immer Sarah
vielen Dank
und jetzt hier in der Sendung eine erste
Nachrichtenübersicht und die hast du
Hannah die USA planen übereinstimmenden
Medienberichten zufolge der Ukraine
international geächtete Streumunition zu
liefern bisher gibt es dafür keine
offizielle Bestätigung der US-Regierung
ein Sprecher des Weißen Hauses teilte
lediglich mit die Lieferung von
Streumunition werde aktiv in Erwägung
gezogen der Einsatz ist hoch umstritten
da Streumunition bereits in der Luft
hunderte kleinere Sprengkörper freisetzt
von denen viele nicht sofort explodieren
sie sind deshalb eine große Gefahr für
die Zivilbevölkerung
in der Nacht hat das erneut russische
Angriffe auf zivile Ziele in der Ukraine
gegeben in Lemberg ganz im Westen des
Landes starben dabei laut Behörden
mindestens fünf Menschen mehr als 35
wurden verletzt russische Raketen
zerstörten dort einen Wohnblock noch
immer sind Suchtrupps im Einsatz um
Überlebende zu finden laut dem
Bürgermeister war es der größte Angriff
auf zivile Infrastruktur in Lemberg seit
Beginn des angriffskriegs
in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat die
Bundesanwaltschaft sieben Mitglieder
einer mutmaßlichen islamistischen
Terrorzelle festnehmen lassen ihnen wird
vorgeworfen in Deutschland eine
terroristische Vereinigung gegründet und
anstecke geplant zu haben laut
Bundesanwaltschaft unterstützte die
Gruppe die Terrororganisation ist
damischer Staat die sieben Männer
stammen aus Tadschikistan Turkmenistan
und Kirgistan auch in den Niederlanden
wurden zwei Verdächtige festgenommen
geflüchteten die wegen einer Straftat
verurteilt wurden darf ihr
Flüchtlingsstatus aber erkannt werden
allerdings nur wenn Sie eine
tatsächliche gegenwärtige und erhebliche
Gefahr für die Allgemeinheit darstellen
das urteilte heute der Europäische
Gerichtshof zudem müsse die Straftat
eine außerordentliche schwere aufweisen
erklärten die Richter hintergrund waren
Fälle aus Österreich Belgien und den
Niederlanden
die Landesregierung von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern stellt sich nach
zdf-informationen gegen die Pläne der
Bundesregierung zum Bau eines
flüssig-erdgasterminals auf Rügen laut
landesumweltminister Backhaus fehlten
dem Land verbindliche Zusagen des Bundes
zur Förderung der Region unter diesen
Umständen Lehne man das Projekt ab
morgen wollen Bundestag und Bundesrat
über die Aufnahme des geplanten
Terminals im Hafen Mukran in das LG
Beschleunigungsgesetz entscheiden
die psychischen Belastungen von Kindern
und Jugendlichen durch die
corona-pandemie könnten Schätzungen zur
Folge auch langfristig hohe
wirtschaftliche Kosten nach sich ziehen
zu diesem Ergebnis kommt eine
expertenstudie mehr junge Menschen als
vor der Pandemie litten an Depressionen
Angst oder Essstörungen so
Bundesfamilienministerin Pauls je nach
Szenario könnten die Folgekosten
zwischen 2,8 und 5,6
so sieht es aus heute in der Stadt
saporisha im Süden der Ukraine 37 Grad
am Strand des nipau Flusses fast
unwirklich das Badevergnügen vor dem
Hintergrund dass ich seit Tagen die
Alarmmeldungen überschlagen in denen
sich Russland und die Ukraine
gegenseitig beschuldigen eine Attacke
auf das gleichnamige Atomkraftwerk zu
planen um sie dann dem jeweils anderen
in die Schuhe zu schieben die Menschen
dort mussten lernen mit der Bedrohung
durch russische Angriffe zu leben aber
was ist mit der radioaktiven Gefahr das
Kernkraftwerk ist 55 km von der Stadt
Saarbrücker entfernt die Frage treibt
aber auch bei uns hier viele um
Christian Kirsch jetzt mit Antworten
sechs Reaktorblöcke am russisch
besetzten Ufer des ausgelaufenen
Stausees die Lage im Kraftwerk saporicia
angespannt die Hauptstromleitung häufig
unterbrochen
immer wieder ist die Anlage unter
Beschuss Granaten schlagen ein auch
heute beschuldigen Russen Ukraine und
Ukraine Russen weiter hält die russische
Armee die Anlage besetzt der ukrainische
Geheimdienst will jetzt Hinweise darauf
haben dass zwei Reaktorblöcke mit
Sprengstoff versehen worden das
Bundesamt für Strahlenschutz wird
ständig informiert von der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde und
ist zurückhaltend
was sie zuletzt von denen gehört haben
ist dass sie Teile des Geländes
kontrolliert haben und keine
Sprengladungen finden konnten
andererseits aber nicht Zugang zu allen
Bereichen haben und bei den russischen
Besatzern jetzt auch angefragt haben
Zugang zu den fehlenden Bereichen zu
bekommen um zu überprüfen ob es dort
springladungen gibt
Mitte September vor fast 10 Monaten also
wurde hier der letzte Reaktor
heruntergefahren das sind die
Strahlenbelastung bei einem möglichen
Unfall erheblich dennoch bereitet man
sich auf ukrainischer Seite intensiv auf
den möglichen Austritt von
Radioaktivität vor
Notfallübungen Jodtabletten für die
Bevölkerung
die Brennstäbe in diesem Kernkraftwerk
dem größten Europas müssen weiter
gekühlt werden eine Herausforderung aber
zu bewältigen der künstlich angelegte
kühlteich ist weiter gut gefüllt er
konnte schnell genug von dem absinkenden
Stausee abgeschottet werden das Wasser
im Teich würde noch monatelang zum
Abkühlen der heruntergefahrenen
Reaktoren reichen
die Reaktorblöcke sind vierfach
gesichert eine Sprengung technisch kaum
möglich der Austritt von Radioaktivität
etwa durch Beschuss würde eher regionale
Kontaminationen verursachen eine Art
schernmobil droht nicht
das heißt das insbesondere in
Deutschland der Lebensmittel der
Nahrungsmittelbereich betroffen sein
könnte wenn denn der Wind überhaupt zu
steht das radioaktive Stoffe aus der
Ukraine nach Deutschland kommen könnten
weitergehende Maßnahmen wie zum Beispiel
Evakuierung ein Name Jodtabletten offen
da den Gebäuden wenn mit sehr großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit in Deutschland nicht
notwendig selbst wenn es zu einem
schweren Störfall den saporisieren käme
für die Region allerdings bleibt das
Kernkraftwerk im Kriegsgebiet weiter
eine Bedrohung
wichtige Informationen so jetzt gucken
wir hier auf unsere Smartphones oder
vielleicht haben seit heute nämlich
einen neuen Konkurrenten Mark
Zuckerbergs Konzernen Meter hat den
neuen Kurznachrichtendienst Threads an
den Start gebracht eine
twitter-alternative die ganz ähnlich
funktioniert wie das Original das ist
Frank Bethmann durchaus eine Kampfansage
hat Threads denn das Potenzial Twitter
gefährlich zu werden ja durchaus
mittlerweile mehr als 30 Millionen
Anmeldungen in nur wenigen Stunden das
lässt aufhorchen Start gelungen mehr
aber auch noch nicht immerhin hatte
Twitter zuletzt mehr als 300 Millionen
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer was Freds aber
tatsächlich zu einem ernsthaften
Konkurrenten für Twitter macht sind die
vielen Accounts die der Zuckerberg
Konzern bereits hat allein hinter
Instagram stehen etwa zwei Milliarden
Nutzer alles potenzielle neue Kunden für
Fritz in über 100 Ländern kann man den
Kurznachrichtendienst bereits nutzen in
der Europäischen Union und damit in
Deutschland allerdings noch nicht warum
ist trap denn aktuell noch nicht bei uns
verfügbar ja das liegt daran dass der
Datenschutz in Europa ganz groß
geschrieben wird da zögert der
meta-konzern derzeit offenbar noch
schließlich ist man gebranntes Kind
wegen der Konzerntochter facebook hat
man erst jüngst eine Rekordstrafe
aufgebrummt bekommt andererseits sagte
heute ein Analyst dass man Flats in
wenigen Monaten auch in Deutschland
nutzen können wird dafür ist der Markt
hier einfach zu wichtig wichtig war
heute noch was anderes die zinssorgen
sind zurück die US-Notenbank lässt
durchblicken die Leitzinsen weiter
anzuheben daraufhin stürzte der DAX ab
verloren über 400 Punkte oder 2,5%
vielen Dank Frank für diese Einordnung
die europäische Behörde für
Lebensmittelsicherheit sieht vorerst
keine Gründe die gegen eine erneute
Zulassung des unkrautvernichtungsmittels
Glyphosat sprechen würden einige
Bereiche wie etwa der Einfluss auf die
Artenvielfalt hätten jedoch nicht
bewertet werden können weil
entsprechende Daten fehlten der Einsatz
von Glyphosat ist umstritten von der
krebsforschungsagentur der WHO wurde es
als wahrscheinlich krebserregend
eingestuft auch in diesem Jahr
entscheidet die EU
Landwirtschaftsminister über eine
verlängerte Zulassung
Anselm Kiefer gilt als einer der
bedeutendsten Künstler der Gegenwart
heute ist der Maler und Bildhauer mit
dem deutschen Nationalpreis
ausgezeichnet worden in seiner Laudatio
würde ich der Bundeskanzler Scholz den
78-Jährigen als einen wichtigen
Botschafter eines modernen Deutschlands
der verschüttetes hartnäckig freilege in
seinen weltweit ausgestellten Werken
arbeitet Kiefer deutsche und europäische
Geschichte auf
ich bin um mein Leben Gefahren sagt
einer der Radprofis der Tour de France
heute und man muss bei dem Satz kurz
schlucken weil man unweigerlich denkt
nicht mal drei Wochen zurück Tour des
Swiss rasante Abfahrt von einem Pass in
Graubünden der Schweizer Profi Gino MEDA
stürzt in eine Schlucht er stirbt an
seinen schweren Verletzungen
das Risiko fährt mit bei der Tour de
France speziell wenn es jetzt
Hochgebirge der Pyrenäen geht das war
immer schon so die Debatte um die
richtige Mischung aus Spektakel und
Sicherheit ist aber neu entbrannt Lars
rote man jetzt mit mehr
heute Mittag am Start im
südfranzösischen Tarp seltene Einblicke
in die strategischen Überlegungen des
deutschen Teams Bora Hans Grohe wie man
das Gelbe Trikot des Australier
verteidigen kann
im Fokus heute der mächtige turmallee
die sportliche Leitung warnt hier
besonders vor der türkischen Abfahrt bei
der die Fahrer nicht selten 100
Stundenkilometer erreichen können
Thema Sicherheit ist natürlich ein ganz
ganz großes leider aktuell ganz ganz
präsent in den Köpfen der Rennfahrer wir
als sportliche Leiter versuchen
natürlich die Rennfahrer bestmöglich auf
das Rennen vorzubereiten etwaige
Gefahrenstellen Engstellen Brücken etc
schon im Meeting anzusprechen die
wenigen Stürze bisher bei dieser Tour
verlaufen halbwegs glimpflich anders bei
der Tourismus vor drei Wochen als der
26-Jährige ginomeder so schwer stürzt
dass er seinen Verletzungen erliegt
für seine Teamkollegen von Bahrain
victorious ist diese Tour sicher eine
besondere Herausforderung es ist auch
einfach leider immer noch im Kopf und es
ich mein Gino wird so oder so immer bei
uns im Kopf bleiben
ja und ansonsten haben wir aber auch
gesagt okay wir müssen auch den die
Konzentration oder im Fokus wieder nach
vorne legen weitermachen mehr das
tragischer tot hat dazu geführt dass die
Tour Verantwortlichen der Streckenprofil
noch einmal überarbeitet haben aber ganz
klar auf 3000 Rennkilometer ist es
einfach unmöglich alle Kurven zu
entschärfen
wir werden die Ausschilderung verbessern
und alles Menschenmögliche tun um die
Risiken zu minimieren
sich nur einen Tag des gelben Trikots
erfreuen dürfen am Schluss Anstieg nach
Kotel rekombask kommt es dann zum großen
Duell zwischen den denen Dinge und taddy
pogata diesmal mit dem besseren Ende für
den Slowenen Etappen Sieg für pugatscha
neuer Gesamtführender Jonas Wegener und
Monsieur macron Medien wirksam der erste
Gratulant
und dann immer die Fans auf der Straße
es geht um können klar es geht aber
immer auch um Glück
bei der Kollegin Maybrit Illner geht es
jetzt um die Ampel und um Heizung
Haushalt Abschwung und gleich danach
Robert Habeck zu Gast bei Markus lands
ein spannender politabend also hier im
ZDF und das war noch nicht der letzte
Tipp nee denn gegen 0.30 gibt es dann
unser heute journal Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann morgen sind wir
wieder da schöner
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen vor dem Wetter schauen wir
auf das klimafänomen El Nino im Pazifik
das alle zwei bis sieben Jahre Auftritt
in solchen Jahren ist es wärmer auf
unserem Planeten so wie beim superhel
Nino 2016 auch in diesem Jahr lag die
Temperaturabweichung schon über der 1,5
Grad Marke und die wird wahrscheinlich
erneut überschritten aber was passiert
da eigentlich im Pazifik in der Regel
schieben östliche Passatwinde das
Oberflächenwasser nach Australien dort
wurde verdunstet ist und sorgt für
feucht warme Witterung auf der anderen
Seite des Pazifiks vor der Küste
Südamerikas quillt kaltes Tiefenwasser
nach oben sonnig trocken und kühl ist es
deshalb normalerweise in der Ninja
Jahren Schwächen sich die Passat finde
ab und das warme Oberflächenwasser
schwappt sozusagen zurück die
Wassertemperatur vor Südamerika steigt
an und das warme Wasser verdunstet nun
dort die Folge für Lateinamerika und
Südamerika schwerere Regenfälle und
Stürme Australien dagegen leidet unter
starker Hitze Trockenheit und Dürre
Hitze ist auch in den nächsten Tagen bei
uns ein Thema die kommt nämlich von
Nordafrika hoch und in dieser Luftmasse
sind 30 bis 40 Grad möglich
dementsprechend kühlen Sie die Wohnung
schön aus denn bis zu 9 Grad werden in
der kommenden Nacht dann als tiefswert
erreicht morgen gibt's dann tagsüber
viel Sonnenschein das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 23 bis schon mal 32
Grad im Südwesten und die Hitze in den
nächsten Tagen setzt sich fort dazu dann
kommen einzelne Gewitter und am Sonntag
sind die heftiger ein schöner Abend